This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Christina.
Hi,
I'm paying Lafferty.
Anna.
Oh Hug.
I'm going to send your balls through your ass.
I'm going to suck your balls and understanding your bolts through your ass.
If my balls get your nose.
Oh fuck those balls.
Oh fuck.
Hi.
I'm paying less for these high on pain Lafferty.
They just go crazy on the balls.
Referee ball from
mastery,
Baja.
Sniff my balls.
No
ball scene for like $1,500.
And I do the eyelash on the balls of my feet on the balls.
Like I'd be the ballpoint.
Which one are you dumb hookers out there with sucking my balls
if my boss,
if my boss knows it's one of those calls.
Jay boy
butter.
Um,
w who always does a good job.
Said that one in.
As always,
we're open to getting your emails,
your questions,
your comments,
your music,
your instrumentals,
your songs,
your mash ups,
whatever it may be.
Your Mom's podcast@gmail.com.
There is no house in the email address.
It's your mom's podcast.
They were all taken.
Yeah.
Your mom's podcast at [inaudible] dot com.
Thank you very much DJ boy butter.
Uh,
gene,
there's a lot of exciting things to talk about today.
So many things.
Um,
how are you feeling or are we good man?
Yeah,
just making a person.
Same Shit.
Different toilet.
What about you?
You're kind of a big deal now.
I mean,
am I even allowed to share the same errors?
You,
what are you talking about?
Well,
I mean,
do you want to make the big announcement?
Well,
I think we,
I kinda did it on the sea.
I know people,
some people skip the beginning when we do.
Yeah.
I know.
We do our day and we do our [inaudible] shed over Charles,
Huh?
The dates and the ads and it's a very important messages you guys should know be
skipping g.
So we do that pre roll and I it in the pre roll
last week,
but this week I can get into it more.
Why don't I do it after the break here,
after we officially open.
So,
um,
that's it.
Let's just get the show opened and I'll tell you all about it.
All right,
Jean,
I'm 100% a ball hog.
Let's party.
Let's have some fun Lafferty.
Not that good,
but I'm all right,
let's do it.
Okay.
My first gang,
Bang,
I didn't know like you're supposed to empty the céline out of the enema things.
So it like really did the laxative effect and I just like volcanoes,
Shit.
Like all over everybody.
And it was like the worst and like I was crying in the bathroom.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
So she's saying the first anal scene did was a gang bang,
it sounds like.
Oh it's her first anal ever.
She's really cute.
I think she's really cute.
Young,
very young to do her first anal gang.
Bang.
She may not be 20 years old.
So I guess this is a video.
Blue bands sent this of a supposed to be embarrassing moments for people.
Can we just start with what she said?
Sorry.
Sartre.
Like John Paul,
she must be related to the famous French philosopher is very,
maybe they have similar philosophies.
Similar.
I think is how you pronounce that.
Later.
We learned that similar,
we learned from love after lock up.
Similar
job,
Paul's salts.
What is the most known for?
Okay.
He's only in my favorite French existentialist philosopher.
He believed that existence is before precedes essence versus essence precedes
existence,
which is what the common thought farms was more before that you're a,
your nature was determined for you and he said,
no,
that's not true.
You can be whoever,
whatever you want to be essentially more or less.
That's a very reductive,
but that reduction of choice is very important to him and God doesn't exist and
all that good stuff.
So then this is totally in line with her granddad's.
No,
no.
This is exactly a mirror of that philosophy.
Yeah.
She made a choice.
She made a choice to do gang anal and she didn't know how to use the enema.
Alright,
so she's saying that she,
there's,
I don't,
I've never animated myself before.
God,
what are you fucking knew?
Happy.
Of course,
I shouldn't say this all the time and I see is,
well we'll get into that but,
but there's,
I'm assuming there is salient and then she's saying she did.
I'm not sure I understand what the problem was.
Okay.
My first I a of speak like you're supposed to empty the céline the enema things.
So it like really did the laxative effect and I just like volcanoes,
shit like all over everybody and it was like the worst and like I was crying in
the bathroom,
I cried in the,
I am more effected by her up speak and her vocal fry and then the actual Shitty,
I don't care,
but I'm assuming there's like sailing and you're not supposed to put all of it
up your ass and she,
she did more than she should have or what I understood from what she,
just the way that she explains that is that that say lean is not supposed to go
up there at all.
That's what it sounds like.
Oh,
so then why did they put it in the animus first gang bang.
I didn't know.
Like you're supposed to empty the céline out of the enema things out of the
enema things.
You're not supposed to put it in yourself.
Maybe the céline keeps the Enema,
you know,
fresh smelling like roses.
I don't know.
In other words,
that's how you know it's fresh.
You empty it and then you use it.
So she,
she put the salient in herself.
That's how I,
that's what I'm doing.
I'm assuming she knows.
I'm assuming you're not supposed to put the salient in your butt.
And she did.
She did.
And then she had a lot.
Now here's the thing though.
From what I understand of the enemies is that it's pretty instantaneous.
Like you,
we've seen people give themselves enemas.
The Coffee Lady,
remember you put it up their ass
seeing the light and you kind of wait like five minutes and then you just shut
everything out.
So why the time delay?
That's interesting.
I wouldn't understand animals more.
I need to know more about this Anima and Charlotte and maybe she would explain
to us.
That's a,
I don't know.
She seems like a nice lady.
I like her.
I feel bad for her that you know that that happened.
Well,
she was also like,
she's over it.
She's like,
I was the first time,
but now she's done lots of anal gangbangs and lots of animals and she's fairly
pro.
It's sort of like when you're an open mic or is what I assume the story is like,
you know,
you're like,
God,
I didn't know when I was supposed to go on stage and I believe the light.
I didn't know that meant that I'm ruining the show for everybody.
I love those knuckle tats.
I really do.
And I'm not saying that facetiously.
I know you've talked about it for a long time.
I really don't come to you with them.
I don't,
I don't see them on me either.
But you have a lot of about a tattoo.
The wanting to do the forum thing.
Oh,
I know.
But then it's not me.
It's like we were talking about the person.
You think you are a person.
I'd like to be.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm a nerd.
I'm like that cool clothes.
I'll be like,
that looks cool on somebody else.
Somebody else.
Yeah,
no,
it's not me.
It's not my style.
I can't look how cool she is.
Like she's got very little hair and the cold glasses and I'm just not choker.
Is that what it's called?
Yeah,
I do.
Like she's,
she's cool.
I'm not fucking cool.
I Dunno.
I can't do gang bang anal.
What'd you do gang bang?
Anal on your first day and all.
I thought that's a very,
uh,
what's the word I'm looking for?
Ambitious.
No,
it's very ambitious and we don't recommend it when we shoot scenes.
We were recommended for,
I mean from my production house,
big,
big BGG,
GG,
Beebee,
Beebee beebee anal.
That's a lot.
So every guy goes in her butthole.
Hold that with that,
I dunno.
Yeah,
I think so.
Gang Bang.
Anal.
Yeah.
I think that's what that means.
All you guys are gonna get in that.
But how much money do you think she got for that?
A couple of grand.
That's it.
I think so.
I'm guessing though,
I wonder how they rate that.
Like is there,
there's a flat rate just for the anal and were like,
Hey,
do you want to shoot?
This scene normally pays a thousand but if you do anal [inaudible] hundred and
then she was like,
whoa.
And then they're like,
hey,
if you let like eight guys get in there and do like two grand,
but that's what I'm,
yeah,
but that's what I'm saying.
So let's say the baselines 1500 you're doing anal right.
And then so the anal is like a flat rate of a thousand and they gave us more
than that 1500 and then the agent goes,
but for every additional guy,
yeah,
that's like $100 more.
So in her head she's doing that hooker math of like hooking up is this is
probably like it.
It's not that much.
And then he's like,
you're already letting a guy fuck you in the butt.
Why not let seven?
There's a few more there with it just extends the scene by like 30 minutes.
Then she's like,
yeah,
all right.
You know what I mean?
I know that agent says,
do you want to add a Sunday show ready already there?
I know.
That's what our agent does.
Like what's the big deal?
You're already there.
You May as well let seven more guys come in.
You're Bob.
What's the big deal?
Surely true differences between porn and coffee.
Of course not.
I totally,
I totally get it.
It's like when they tell me they go,
do you want to add a Thursday show?
I'm already there on Thursday.
You Ready?
Making your money and you get greedy.
You see the dollar signs,
you know it's one more dick in your ass.
It's another Dick.
It's another dig.
But it's so worth it.
Like you're already lubed up.
Just fucking do seem to do this scene.
It still makes me laugh that we call porno movies.
See like there seems to work tomorrow,
right?
Like it's not because we should call them different things cause people that
make legit movies,
they shoot scenes.
These are scenes too,
but they're different.
I know,
I know.
They are very different.
Not that I'm judging.
I'm very,
I like pornography and I'm very pro.
I'm pro porn to pornography and people making a living however they have to.
But it's funny that you should call it.
Yeah,
it's on a scene.
You know what I'm saying?
And they're acting and they kind of are proof.
It's performative.
Definitely.
Yeah,
that's true.
It's not like regular amateurs laying around having sex.
No,
it's,
it's hard.
She just took,
yeah.
How many decks in her,
but I don't know that we just know it was an anal Gangbang.
Oof.
Here's another,
that's gotta be so painful and you're another war story.
Loved.
I love the shine.
I can't think of like an embarrassing,
I'm kidding.
Like I'm not afraid to like act like an idiot at time.
You know,
like if you're doing an angel,
maybe some people might come out.
Um,
if you're stuck in some day,
can you do an a little bit too,
too?
Um,
too much.
You know,
you may throw up over the cock,
he is the number of things,
but you just call him like,
hey,
whatever,
wipe and go.
No,
that would really,
that would not be fun for you.
It's definitely not for me.
No,
I'm,
I'm in the though or not,
but I kind of get it like,
you know,
especially after having given birth once already,
I don't do it.
Like today we went for an ultrasound and the nurse was like,
oh,
I'll leave the room so you can take your pants off and not right.
No need no fucking care.
You're going to look at my badge and two seconds.
I think the more kids people have to the last day.
You care about modesty and,
dude,
what are you kidding me?
Oh,
my body's a fucking village.
Good.
Me Too.
I'm always like,
I'm old now.
You can look.
Doesn't matter.
Okay.
Who sees it rising good here.
It's your problem.
Like you have to look at this pile of shit.
Go for it.
Yeah.
Oh,
I look like I've had multiple kids.
Your body looks better now than it ever has.
What are you talking about?
I feel like it looks like I've had triplets.
You look better now than you did when we first started dating.
You look fantastic.
No,
not then.
We first started dating when we first got married and that when we first started
dating,
yes.
You look fit.
You look just like you did we first started any?
No,
you're skinny.
You're fit.
You look great.
Please.
Are you talking about Peyton?
Peyton knows the truth.
Give yourselves my body's all stretched out.
I think I would be bothered more by this shit if I was the guy doing the scene
by brown bear brown than Puke.
I mean personally,
I mean I'm not in a metaphor.
I mean I know it because vomit smells horrible hate volume,
but shit would be like a real like I don't know.
I'm trying to think what could I recover from more quickly as far as any day.
I Dunno when I,
I could stranger shitty some version of being excited by the vomit occurring
because of my pee pee down her mouth.
Sure.
So I'd be like,
that's pretty cool.
I did that,
I did that.
But the Poop,
I'd be like her and it's a stranger shit.
It's not like your beloved's.
No,
I know.
Cause if I that it's shit right.
That put too much salient.
But before the scene shot.
Cause if I shit on you,
would you even be phased?
No,
nothing.
Nothing about you would faze me.
Yeah.
Nothing.
Same.
I mean I don't know.
It would feel weird to be all warm.
Like I always picture the temperature of something like that.
It's warm.
Yeah,
like a hot turd.
Their bar,
they're both warm.
The puke and the,
I don't like that the shit will be a little extra hot.
I think this is more weight to it.
Yeah.
Oof.
A pukes harder to clean out those tap it out of our own show
uttered.
You could just kind of pick up unless it's diarrhea at a wash and you gotta
shower you of course you have to share on both cases.
Yeah.
This guys is pretty funny.
This guy is here.
You know what?
This sometimes is a bit embarrassing when you come,
when you come to a point is that you know like you think you don't know the girl
very nice to meet the the screen and then it goes here is you don't remember.
You did my first barker.
I'll see him.
Boy,
most of the time after when the girls say it's like you remember then you know
like everything starts working in the brain and then you kind of like look back
500 625 and a half scenes and then somehow it comes slowly blurry back.
Yeah.
And then there is a moment and you're like all rather remember
you could totally be your dad's story about it and any number of people you've
met.
Well of course I'm thinking more of his accent,
but yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
No,
his accent.
But he could have the same story.
You can be like,
nice to meet you.
Yeah,
I've never,
and then she'd be like,
excuse me,
you don't remember me?
No.
Easily.
I want to ask him,
right?
Yes.
Miami beach.
Yeah.
I wanted to ask my dad,
how many women do you think you've slept with?
And he said,
not enough.
That's a great answer.
And see it is a funny,
funny answer,
but yeah,
I'll clearly,
easily,
I mean,
yeah,
no,
I don't think my dad ever did it for a living,
but this guy legit.
Has this happened all the time?
Yeah.
You realize that?
Oh,
he's like,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
That's weird.
Right?
You're like a half.
I had sex with you.
Hi Jackie.
Related inside of you.
I think I did.
Yeah,
I think I remember you.
You know what's interesting too is that they call it boy girl,
girl boy.
Is that a male,
female or woman or man,
it's also very infantilized in a weird thought of that.
That's true.
Right?
Like it's a,
it's by growl,
but it's like you can hear this is a pretty good point of what the dumb slot.
Yeah.
As I,
as I bug out by God,
you can hear her damage talking.
That's why bag.
Yeah.
There she is.
Hello.
I actually needs a cream pie scene.
It was like one of my first scenes in industry and was totally fine.
The whole scene.
And we go to do the final shot and um,
it's a cream pie,
so he's pulling out of me and instead of a cream pie,
it was a period pie.
Oh.
Oh no,
it was a strawberry shortcake.
Yeah.
Damn.
These girls go varsity on their first season.
She's like,
it's one of my first scenes.
Do you think they like,
but she might've made that extra 40 bucks.
That's good for the extra hundred or the agent.
It's the agent.
Yeah.
Age is like,
he's go by the morning after pill.
You got 40 bucks in your pocket now or is it my phone yet?
Yup.
That's uh,
by,
uh,
two tickets to the movies and get coke and fucking popcorn.
And you know,
they weren't thrilled.
You know,
that the set,
the director was not sympathetic.
And like you said,
it's the rule of the scene.
That's the part that actually makes me sad.
Yeah.
Because the story is kind of like,
ah,
I,
I empathize with how embarrassing that would be for her.
Yeah,
you're right.
They'd be like,
great,
now I don't even fucking have a cream pie.
Is there the whole point?
Yeah.
She's like,
I'm sorry.
How long did this period shit last with you?
God,
I remember Jules Ventura when she was in here,
we asked her how she deals with the period and she said they put a sponge up
there.
Oof.
Just for people who are curious that yeah,
they just put a sponge and then you can work when you're still having your
period.
I didn't realize that you actually did some porn cause it looks like you're here
talking about this one.
Probably trying to like be sexy for some social media thing and passing gas on
the camera.
Trying to be like funny.
They sexy like oh it's work from you real quick.
And I like,
the thing is it was almost like live stream so it could even be like taken down.
It was just on their life.
That's hilarious.
Foreign gene.
Oh Geez.
I'm worried.
That would definitely be your story.
You'd be like,
oh I found this.
Yeah,
but here's the thing.
That would be my whole genre.
They'd be like,
you're the bigger the fart person on the foreign ministers.
Yeah.
I wouldn't even fuck,
I wouldn't do any of the anal or any Korean pouch.
All farts,
all farts bar as far as just far as video can never find that drop on it.
That's the easiest one to do as a fart stuff.
Are you kidding me?
Far and it's already in my lane.
Yeah,
I know.
Right.
Where is that for and dammit,
I can never find it far.
Shaft a r t.
Um,
all right,
so we should
probably tell him right now.
You're talking about your boy girl,
boy,
girl.
So this is what happened.
I mentioned it in the last pre roll and I said I would get it.
I didn't want to do it in that pre-roll because that was after we had shot the
video and recorded the episode and then you would have only some audio of it and
not on the video.
It didn't make sense.
I had to move my Salt Lake City shows.
Um,
surely,
surely teddy shows and I had to cancel Australia.
Even looking for a date to come back.
It's a little more complicated when you go abroad.
Far Away Monster.
Um,
yeah.
But the reason why is because I booked a role in a major motion
picture movie.
Where's the chips in a bowl?
Where is the fucking cat eating kibble?
You didn't even prepare.
This is a big announcement.
Oh,
well you know,
sometimes you don't get there.
Where's the cat eating kibble?
I don't have that one,
but
it was,
I'm really excited about it actually.
Of course you are.
It's your first boy girl scene that you've ever done.
Here's a all I was thinking for,
for people that don't know if you had asked me,
uh,
just over 16 years ago when I got here,
if you'd asked me what do you think you'll probably end up doing it and you
think you'll be working making a living as a standup comedian or as an actor in
like shows and movies.
I would be like a hundred percent as an actor.
There's no way I'm doing standup.
But that's what I would have thought if you'd ask.
Yeah,
I can take my mind back to,
to that time,
you know,
cause that's what you really want.
And I remember that's what I could imagine shortly after you landed here in la
and that was like your,
your thing,
you were an actor,
you were in a play.
Yeah,
that's right.
You were doing classes were really,
isn't it interesting though,
how life kind of give to a detour know,
and I remember,
you know for
a lot of people do this,
when they come out here,
they sign up for one of the,
you know,
it's Io,
it's a UCB Improv Olympics,
Improv Olympics,
uh,
the Groundlings.
And then what's the Chicago based one?
A second city,
second city.
So when I moved out here,
I looked up,
I saw that like will Ferrell and some other couple other people,
uh,
were from the Groundlings and I was like,
that's where I'm going to go.
Yeah,
I did that one too.
So I went to the Groundlings,
I eye test,
I tested and I got to skip a level and then I did a series with them and then I
did level two with them.
And then you go to this thing called writing lab,
but you have to wait for it,
they call you.
And then when,
then it's about writing your marriage when you got that.
And when they called me,
I had just started making $50 a set emceeing,
like getting paid to do shows.
And I was a couple of years in to stand up.
And I remember even though I wanted to take it,
I go,
it was kind of that thing that you go,
do I go do that or do I put more into the thing that's already kind of starting
to work for him?
Right.
And I thought,
you know,
if I go do that,
it's going to take away from this standup thing that I'm,
it's not just that I'm making money doing it instead,
I'm enjoying doing,
I'm,
I'm working at it now.
And so I passed on it and they go,
well,
we'll only call you one more time to see if you wouldn't do it the next time.
And I said,
okay.
They called again,
I passed again.
And then it was like,
Hey,
I'm,
I'm doing stand up full,
you know,
full throttle.
And then I did,
you know,
I did a number of auditions,
um,
for different things,
you know,
and I booked that huge subway campaign,
which if you've never heard this,
I mean,
it was pretty nutty that at one point you were going to play Jerrod's derelict
brother.
Yeah.
On a like a,
this would have been so that flow from a,
the progress she's made a fortune be flow.
The way that this was presented to me,
you are going to be the,
you know,
the counter to Jared on subway and if this,
these ads work out,
it's just going to run all the time.
It'll be your life.
Now.
I remember when you got that in,
you and I were like,
oh my God,
you're going to be a millionaire.
Oh yeah,
this is crazy.
This is crazy,
man.
I was 25.
I know.
That's how long ago that was.
I know in 2005 flew to New York.
We shot commercials.
Here's the thing,
there are commercials somewhere.
Somebody has these and uh,
you know,
I dunno,
I've never gotten a hold of them,
but they just never aired.
And the reason they air right
was fate that my agent didn't even know.
You know,
who I think notified me,
I want to say it was Larson and I want to say because he read something,
what happened was unrelated to the campaign,
it had nothing to do with the campaign.
The VP of marketing at subway resigned.
He resigned.
And this is a common thing in any business practice.
Uh,
he resigned because he was of age.
He was 60 something years old.
A new VP is high.
So the new VP of marketing,
what they do is you kill all the other guys ideas for two reasons.
If they're bad and they don't work out,
they'd be like,
what the fuck did you keep that for?
Right.
You should.
Yeah.
And if they're good,
then you're basically crediting your predecessor.
You know what I mean?
So you don't want,
it's like in the,
in the wild when Elian takes over a family.
That's right.
He kills all the young of the lioness and then reproduce it for themselves,
their own made.
And that's a very common practice in,
in major corporates,
evil.
So I have a sip here.
I didn't even get to see if they worked out.
I just got the call that the campaign was dead and I was like heartbroken mostly
because I was like,
this was going to be a huge jump,
you know,
a big platform for me to get on.
And be funny.
The commercials were funny,
you know,
they're their corporate commercial funder.
Your ads memorize that song by rat round and round.
They licensed that song and I'd be like driving up and sing in that and then I
crashed my car into this thing at a port Jareds fuck up brother.
And then you had the whole idea was for people.
Some of you may have heard it,
but if you haven't heard it,
the reason was Jared could only push healthy subs and they're like,
we need to be able to advertise unhealthy ups.
And they're like,
you could do that time.
So while Jared would say Turkey sub,
it's healthy,
I go chicken parms not bad either.
And then that would be the Ed,
you know?
That's right.
You were like the slovenly brother that could plug all the analysis.
The downside of being just the subway ad guy,
of course I have the added benefit that if that had worked out,
I would now be associated with a convicted child.
Pornographer serving major that,
and I think it would have affected your standup material shore because it's a
major corporation and they would not,
you would not be making the jokes that you'd make their special.
Or the worst thing would be,
you know,
I could just stand up,
but everyone would be like,
tell us to eat fresh.
Like dude,
the fucking line.
I'd be like,
all right.
And then I'd have like subs kind of carved it out to the stage,
making jokes about food.
It'll be fucking blurb because on the one hand,
it's kind of a guilt.
It's a gilded cage.
Like the girl that does flow,
that progressive girl,
she was an act like an Improv actress.
I remember.
She's great,
she's really great and she does a great job with those ads.
But I'm saying that you're kind of locked in as an identity.
Like that's it.
She's flow forever.
And in our business it's very hard to get out of that.
It's hard to get out of.
But the upside is that she has probably great
and she's,
you know,
she's got it,
but it'd be very hard to do anything else creatively,
I think for her.
So,
so there's that that goes down.
You know,
I do a couple of other commercials.
I did a dominoes ESPN one I partnered up.
Yeah.
Then I did a couple other commercials.
I'm trying to remember.
Oh,
I remember you did dot.
Yes.
Right.
And then,
um,
no,
that wasn't with cat.
You did a sitcom.
You did Jay [inaudible].
I did a couple of things on him and then like I booked,
try to think of the things I,
I booked a episode of workaholics were,
I had a great scene that got cut out entirely.
That was going to be like my,
all right.
Like I booked a great scene.
I booked a scene on,
was it pushing up daisies,
the ABC show where it wasn't.
I had one scene with let's say five or six lines and they cut it down to one
word.
So all these things where you're like,
Jesus Christ.
And I,
by the way,
as that's happening,
I'm moving further along in standup.
So I'm like,
I kind of just see it as like this side thing where I'm like,
you know,
I really wished this would work out,
but it just is not,
you know.
But the point being that you've had,
it's pretty ridiculous.
16 years of near misses.
Like you quite literally like you get cast in the big Setcom but your line gets
cut out.
You get flown out to New York to try out for the producers to read for this
movie.
That's the most recent one.
I don't remember if we talked about on this show.
We did not,
but I didn't want to give away.
I Dunno.
It's like,
like kind of insight.
So I flew out,
I tested for,
I auditioned for a movie over the summer and uh,
the audition went really well and then they flew me to New York to test.
So when you test,
they basically have producers in the room,
like higher ups,
the director,
and then you're also on film with somebody who is cast in the movie.
And it's usually between you and like a handful maybe of other people.
Yeah.
In this case it was one other person.
All right.
Wow.
It gave me the heads up.
You were really close.
Yeah.
And here's the thing,
I even though when I didn't get it,
I was bummed party,
you start to go like,
just kind of make sense because here's the thing you learned about film casting.
Almost all the financers in film go look at things like,
well what else have they done?
And this is like the,
the screwy circle of,
of this,
of things not working out is that they'll go,
well,
act or one has never done anything.
Actor two's been in 10 movies in three television shows.
And then they go,
oh well we want it to be the proven actor.
So they go with Acthar to which happened to be in that movie.
They called me and he goes,
um,
the other actor was a well known actor and he goes,
they gave it to him and I was like,
yeah,
they're going to give it to them every time because he's a proven entity.
And that's why it's so hard to break into things like
Sitcom or a film because a lot of the,
first of all,
a lot of sick time actors have been doing [inaudible] since they were four and
they've been in the system.
There's a system that Kinda,
you know,
it's the same people over and over again.
That's why you see the same five actors,
uh,
doing everything in the Sitcom world and in the film world.
Cause you're kind of,
once you're in early,
you're in,
you're in the system.
It's really hard to break in.
I almost didn't go in on this audition.
It's the right [inaudible] just booked.
That's the funniest thing.
Oh that's right.
I remember you were like,
don't know,
like when you get an audition at first it comes in an email and it just says you
have an audition,
you know,
this Friday and it has all the details.
Has the breakdown of the part,
what it is,
who's directing it,
who wrote it.
Sometimes it has wind,
it'll shoot and then it has,
you know where the audition is.
So it was the week,
the week after my special came out and I'm doing all this press every day.
It's like you're doing a TV thing,
you're doing two things with this.
You're doing Conan,
you're doing radio that you're going to test.
In the middle of all that.
I pick up my phone,
it says you have a audition,
you know this day.
And I'm like,
all right.
I don't,
I don't even,
I just don't even answer.
The next day I have all like three more things at press.
Then I get,
uh,
an email says,
can we confirm you for the audition?
And I just wrote like,
no,
I got too much going on.
Which is not unusual.
I pass on a lot of auditions because of our schedules.
Like we have touring,
schedule our kid things in our own,
you know,
we have things going on.
So most of the time I would say I consider those things and I'll turn down
auditions,
you know?
So this time my agent happened to call me.
He never calls when I say I can't make it to this,
and he goes,
the director requested to see you for this.
I really think you should try to go in.
So I'm like,
okay,
well get me a new day because I can't do it.
Yeah.
Well the other thing that people don't know if you're not in the Chavez,
they always have like a,
we get your time,
here's the time and you can't,
it's really hard to change that.
They tell you the time and that's it.
And like you could not have an childcare,
you can be on the other side of town.
And I don't care
for other,
for people that don't,
aren't aware that sometimes you get a 6:00 PM 6:37 PM it'll say,
hey,
you have an audition tomorrow morning at 10:00 AM and you're like,
it's a prepared.
Like,
I mean,
I have this kid,
I'm going to put them down and I mean,
how am I going to be ready for that?
It's like that.
It'll happen that quickly,
you know?
Yeah.
So anyways,
I take the,
of course after he tells me that I take the audition,
I go on it.
Uh,
I thought it went really well.
But that's the thing is most of the time when you audition and you think it goes
well,
nope.
Never even hear anything.
And sometimes when you think the addition went poorly,
they'll call you and be like,
you have a call back.
You're going back to see me.
Like what?
So you just never know the formula
the director told me or gave my agent some feedback and then was like,
tell him to come to my house now.
He didn't say tell him.
He said tell him to give him my number.
And then I talked to him and he's like,
do you want to work on the scene?
And I was like,
sure,
sorry,
I have to leave for your back and the shower.
Is it a 3:00 AM kind of meeting or what's going to go on?
So now,
but he was like super,
I dunno this the nicest like guy in this business I think that I've ever met is
this director.
I went over there,
we talked about the scene.
We,
we ran it a few times.
How many,
what was it,
a boy?
Girl.
Boy.
Cause it was just the two of us.
It was just boy.
And did you give yourself an animal before the scene?
I took all the salient out,
but I did do that just to make sure.
And then it's like,
hey,
you know,
he worked on it.
Then he's like,
oh you still have to go back and test and then you still have to get approved by
the all the other producers and the studio executives parent May.
It's so nerve wracking.
Well I,
but I also was I think with age,
like how long I've been doing this.
I was like,
yeah,
okay,
sure.
And then I was also cool with the fact that they might say,
hey,
you know,
you,
they liked you but no one needs another movie.
Well anyone,
you know,
I just kind of was just like,
yeah,
that's fine.
I mean,
I understood that it's likely not going to happen.
So it just kind of liberating.
It is kind of in the,
well,
I'm swinging for,
you know,
the back of the room here and if it doesn't happen it probably won't happen.
And I also realized that like,
you know,
it doesn't,
it's not my livelihood and thank God I don't rely on it to have my bills paid or
anything.
You know,
it was like
in the figure skating world,
they've already won the metal and you could tell there's so much more relaxed
when they're doing those moves in the rank.
Right.
Totally way looking at it.
Yes.
He already got the,
you already have your gold medal in standup.
So,
and then uh,
oh.
Then the director texted me,
give me a call when you can't.
I'm like,
motherfucker,
like he's being nice with to tell me that,
you know,
it's always that one.
It's a community.
I didn't get it cause he was so nice.
I thought he's going to be like,
I just want you to know that love you.
You're my favorite.
Give him a call.
And he's like,
hey man,
you're doing the movie.
You both so crazy.
I couldn't believe it.
I really was overjoyed.
Like I said,
it's just something I've wanted to do for so long.
So long gene.
So the movie shoots in Atlanta,
um,
it's starring Mark Wahlberg,
crazy.
Rose Byrne,
Octavia Spencer.
Uh,
there's a couple other comics and it,
tig Notaro was in it.
Oh,
Eliza slessinger is in it.
Um,
not anyways,
it's a great cast and a great script and I'm just,
I can't believe that I get to do it.
Who's your fucking movie by movie white?
Of course.
Yeah.
Allen.
Rachel,
she's great.
Unattractive because I'd like to make sure that she's not attractive.
She is attractive.
Oh yeah.
She's very well,
can we change that?
I don't think so.
I mean,
I could ask her to like shave her head or something like that before he make her
do the skull.
It.
I don't know that I get that power,
but also just it,
I'll suggest it what Jane,
I'm very proud of you and I'm very happy for you and I know you've wanted this
for so long and we've had so many successes on this.
And by the way,
that is the thank you very much.
And I know you don't have much.
I've wanted to do something like this.
The other thing is that the next call I get is like,
what are we gonna do about these dates?
So now I have to move dates,
you know,
and it's,
it's one of the ones were trust me.
Um,
I don't like doing that,
especially to people that are coming to see me.
I like,
I,
I do super appreciate everybody's support in the live standup stuff,
but the way that these,
these things usually go is,
you know,
the movie takes,
they own you for the time that they shoot.
That's how the contract ends of dollars in production.
And Yeah,
not to me,
believe me,
have not mark Wahlberg.
Yeah.
I'm not making anything crazy on this.
It's so interesting.
I was listening to Kathy Griffin and she was giving an interview about when,
uh,
she was working on a Michael Jackson video as an extra back in the 80s.
And she said that Michael Jackson would just blow off going to sat and he and
Macaulay Culkin would go to shopping at the mall.
Yeah.
And she asked the director,
hey,
how much money is he blowing by doing that?
And he goes,
I'm million dollars a day and this is back in the entities by the way.
So there's a lot of money that goes into these films and to crazy music videos.
It's,
it's such a huge production that that kind of becomes the priority in Showbiz
business and then everything else.
So look,
I don't know if I'll ever book another job again.
Well,
I'm just saying,
I mean it was 16 years for the first one,
so I don't know if I'll ever booked another job again,
but I'm going into this with like the attitude of like,
I want to enjoy this experience.
Yeah.
Shooting a,
a big movie I get to do.
Um,
I have like,
you know,
some really funny lines.
I guess it's a fun character.
I get to play.
I'm playing in brother-in-law and who's basically kind of a loud mouth.
Don't say too much because I know I'm kind of this perfect.
Are you a piece of shit scum bag?
Cause I feel like no,
no,
no.
I'm not a patient system.
I mean there's a bunch of makeup scene bloods,
a shower scenes.
Uh Yeah.
Yes there are.
Yes.
But I don't think so.
It's acting.
We Act.
We don't babe.
I just,
I gave,
I come in,
I take,
I take a shower.
Uh,
there's like a morning blowjob and then we go,
we drive over and we see our relatives but that's just,
I didn't write it.
Um,
talk to Sean.
All right,
well I'll see my buddy.
It's funny too that I'm going to see one of my old best friends,
my old roommate lives in Atlanta with his family is all still see Justin.
That's good.
You have a friend there in Atl.
Even case was going to come down one weekend.
Good.
Cause he's not too far and well,
it should be a great time,
you know?
Well,
I'm going to miss you.
I'm gonna miss you too.
Baby jeans is getting miss you.
You're going to be gone for like a mom.
A cut.
Well I'm a couple of weekends.
I'm a fly home then a couple that I'm standing,
I'm actually going to try to do stand up in the area.
So look for an announcement of a,
a couple shows in the,
at least in the greater somewhere drivable to Atlanta.
Now if you get a movie wife too,
I get a temporary husband while you're gone or percent.
Yeah.
Who Do I get to pick?
Well you have to audition people the same way that I auditioned comics only.
No,
I don't want them.
No comedian.
I'm,
I'm married to a comedian bay.
Your your your scene partner is a comic actress.
Right.
Okay.
God,
we're going to have so much fun,
but she stuck with it.
What Babe?
What?
I've never shot these types of scenes.
You know,
you're seeing of the boy.
Girls are seen work.
Tom,
how are you going to prepare for your ceiling roll boy method like Jim Carrey
did and man on the moon.
Are you going to be one of those Douche bags?
It's like I made character all the time.
Don't call me Tom.
My character name is frank or whatever.
Anytime someone says Tom,
I'll be like,
where?
Who are you talking to?
Russ?
I can't wait for you to become that kind of a movie star.
Yeah.
And Are you going to be,
yeah.
Are you going to demand that people can't make eye contact with you on set?
Oh yeah.
Nobody look at me.
It's in my contract.
It's really,
yeah.
No I'm,
I'm basically,
it's funny cause I'm going back to,
I'm an open miker of on the acting the movie and the movie world.
Yeah.
So I get,
I'm doing like introductory level everything,
which is great.
That's a great way to step into it.
Craft services,
that means free food every day.
Onset can't beat that.
You can't go crazy cause I don't want to be all bart on it.
You know,
you don't want to get burnt fat.
No.
God did you see him?
You know,
shot a special,
which I heard was amaze.
Oh,
I heard the opposite.
Oh really?
I heard that it went really well.
I heard it went really well from people in Philly.
And also you'd be surprised,
but Burt himself actually said how amazing.
Yeah.
Not like him at all.
It's as though he called over here the next morning and told us how great,
how great it went and how was the best show of all time.
And I was like,
this sounds very much like you.
So modest damper.
Like honestly,
I'm sure where
he's so like quiet understated about stuff.
And then I saw pictures of them.
Yeah,
it was bad.
No,
I mean there's bodies so,
well that's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Cause he did it shirtless for this special,
another shirtless special,
which is so funny that there'll be
two specials of him shirtless and you will just be like,
which one?
Like normally you'd be like,
Hey,
what's special are you talking about?
And you'd be like,
oh,
the one where the guy's shirtless.
Yeah.
Now they're gonna be like,
you know how that shirtless guy,
the one where he's a little less fat is the one I'm talking about.
Can,
the neat part is that because that'll be his calling card.
Like Larry the cable guy working can't a sleeveless.
I hope it's the most special of all time.
Just so it solidifies that.
He has to be sure.
Because at that point if he walks around with a shirt somewhere,
people be like,
you're being a dick.
Like just take your fucking shirt off.
He's got to do it shortly.
And when he goes wherever and he's going to be like 80 years old,
he's going to do he's shirtless course and let's be honest,
we're all gonna,
you know,
we work at trying to keep these shit bodies in some type of shape.
He's going to fall off,
you know,
at some point in the next few years.
And like when he gets really fat again,
I can't wait to see him have to take this because it's actually,
here's the thing,
it really is actually funnier to see him shirtless,
more out of shape.
So,
yeah,
that's Kinda the whole point,
right.
To see him look like shit.
I hope he doesn't get in shape.
No,
I hope,
I hope not either.
Leanne Kreischer started her own podcast called wife of the party.
It's a great name.
It's a great part.
I listened to the first half of it.
She's doing,
um,
some special diets.
She was talking about the beach body Diet.
I think it's called birds.
No,
definitely not.
So that's,
you know,
anyway,
give Leanne's podcasts.
Uh,
uh,
listen.
Yeah,
yeah.
She's a friend of ours,
but a lot of stuff going on.
Yeah.
A lot of stuff going on.
So we wrapped up our prisons show
or maybe that was a throat throat come.
We wrapped up by her presence.
She'll love after lock up and were devastated because that was the seventh and
final episode last night.
Jean.
Yeah,
that was a great short runs series.
I mean,
we talked about it for a while.
Um,
but yeah,
it was,
I was sad that it came to an end,
but I don't want to ruin it for people because I've ever since we brought it up,
I got a lot of messages from people saying they're,
they're diving into it.
Oh.
So let's not,
yeah.
But I mean,
now it's,
you know,
it's clearly it's made,
it's,
it's over at this point.
You should have seen it if you're watching it.
Well,
no,
cause that new episode,
the last one just dropped like,
right.
This episode is,
Oh,
we're in the future.
Yeah.
Right.
Oh,
it's PR,
but it's,
it's alarming.
Uh,
some of it is very sad.
Some of it is so upsetting to me,
especially the one,
there's a mother of three children and just,
I don't want to give it too much away,
but she really fucks up her kids' lives for,
uh,
the chance to marry this convicted felon.
It's pretty fucking amazing.
Yeah.
That,
and then I don't think there were too many surprises on that.
I was surprised.
Oh,
ah,
no,
there is a which one,
which one?
White boy in Florida member.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It does not say it or no,
you know that in case people haven't seen it,
you haven't seen it.
I don't know.
But there's definitely a couple of surprises and then that's actually one where
you go like,
oh,
that's good that,
that,
that the surprise happened.
Well,
what's so funny is that you and I totally flipped.
So like at first we were like,
these prisoners are scumbags or taking advantage of these innocent people and
now we're like,
these prisoners are just like nice people trying to,
they're just trying to,
our lives and these assholes on the outside are totally taking advantage of
them.
And like they all get out,
these guys get out and the women are like,
what are we getting married?
Why is there a big ceremony?
I want to wear my dress,
I want to have my bridal shower.
It's like,
dude,
he just got out of prison.
He shell shocked.
He's traumatized.
He doesn't have a job.
He slept in a check in with his parole officer like every hour,
you know,
he can't even leave La county.
Like,
why are you putting demands on it?
With most of them.
They'd been with the guy for awhile and they have so little compassion,
understanding and empathy for their situation.
There was the outsider,
you're like,
how do you not,
this guy's trying to adjust after six years in prison.
Why aren't you having a little more like,
you can't see that.
Well,
the Canadian guy especially,
there's a couple in Toronto and the guy like clearly traumatized,
looked like he may have been kidnapped,
beaten.
He's total shell shock total.
The life has just drained from him.
He's so bummed out and she's like,
I want to have our wedding
Dobbs diamond shoes.
I want it to be,
it's my diet.
The best is like,
can we stop it and dude,
Suntech Tuxedo shopping and he's like,
I can't actually,
I got out of prison yesterday.
She's like,
yeah.
He's like,
I don't want really want to show up or Tuxedos,
right?
She was like,
why not?
No.
She goes,
don't you left me?
I guess you don't love me.
I guess I want to be my husband.
I'm like,
oh wow.
That's like too of what?
You guys are crazy.
The people that are dating these fools are crazier than the inmates.
To her credit,
she's the one that when they do decide to just do it quickly,
she's like,
you know all I really care about being married and she,
she's less about,
oh I need the big thing that I actually just want to be married.
Yeah,
she kinda got the priority of love.
Don't know.
Then there's the lady on heroin.
That was awesome.
So I mean,
here's from,
from what I've learned about present shows presence,
not the place you get clean from heroin.
From what I understand,
prison's not like a Malibu Rehab Clinic.
It's kind of where you find new suppliers.
Like did drugs are still going on?
Yeah.
You should start here in prison.
I'm not,
I kind of want to get high all the time.
I would be dead if I were in prison from God.
Are you kidding me?
Yeah.
I would be high all the time if I could be in jail.
I would just be shooting scenes and shooting heroin at least pot.
I try to be high on pot all day everyday if I could be.
I Dunno.
I would also,
it's funny that I think we talked about it,
but none of those people,
they all are just sad.
They just want to say,
yeah,
they say just have their heartbroken.
You know,
too many times no.
Like
this person's in prison.
They can't hurt me.
Well,
and what's funny too is that a lot of these prisoners are just hustling.
The people on the outside,
uh,
there's this great guest of this woman.
So there's this one woman who she's dating a guy in prison and she sends him
$200 a month,
which for her,
she cannot afford $200 a month to send to.
She's on such a tight budget that she only has $40 left at the end of every
month for just like herself stuff.
The guy who from his photo,
you'd be like,
oh,
this is a manipulator of psychopath for total scum.
Fuck yeah.
And then her friend comes home,
her friend comes over who's been in prison and she goes,
yeah,
I used to scam like two guys at the same time because you want someone to tell
you I'll take care of you.
I love and also to send you that money.
That commissary money.
Yeah.
Cause they want their fucking snacks.
Core nuts.
And there was definitely watch orange is the new black.
What about these motherfuckers that don't have anyone to do that?
They just don't have shit.
I mean that's gotta be,
how is that even fair?
I think from what I know from orange is the new black.
You can also work shitty prison jobs and make like 35 cents an hour and then
that can go towards your commissary.
Hustlin there's such hookers,
dude.
And then there's one fucking hooker who's hustling.
The sweet truck driver on the outside bums me out the most.
She's like,
don't you love me?
And once you pay my legal bills and he's like,
you got caught with drugs and a phone.
They're saying eight to 12 years was like,
oh,
I've got your back baby back.
He's pathetic.
He's,
he really is.
It's really sad.
Pathetic.
Are you ready for perhaps the greatest thing a listener has ever done it to us?
You talked about this at lunch before we sat down and record this.
I'm so excited.
I didn't expect it and that's just great.
Yeah.
Here's the email.
Uh,
hey,
Tom and Jean for the last few days,
I've been having a blast calling people with the Christina soundboard I made.
Oh Shit.
I called random people named Jean and Tom,
but this might be the best one.
Oh dear.
I told a phone,
sex operator.
My name was Bert.
I hope you enjoy it as much as I did.
Making it,
keeping them high and tight.
Tony W.
Oh my goodness.
It's just,
it is a maze.
You Ready?
I'm ready.
Here we go.
You've been talking about,
hello.
How are you?
It's good honey.
I'm sitting here
with my girlfriend,
Christine
truck and trailer RAF and symbols and get into a little bit of Scout Master
boot.
Oh,
I can do that,
baby.
Okay.
Oh No.
Why is he sounded like bigfoot.
Well,
he probably,
he just disguise his voice a little bit.
Scat play.
I know,
but I don't know.
I read where I want to put Christina.
No,
Hi Annie.
How are you?
You have to shit.
I do.
You want to take my knife?
Swamp Shit.
Stanhope Masturbate.
Shit.
I'll take a shit for you.
I'll take a nice shift.
You gotta take a shit?
Take a shit baby.
Oh
Shit.
Yeah.
I like Golden Man Shit.
They're like,
oh,
nice and warm baby.
I like that.
Oh,
ah.
I've never shit in the toilet.
That's the first time for everything,
Baby.
It's too hard and is a little high.
But if you squat down,
it's all right.
I can do that whole job.
Thank you.
Wow.
You like that?
Hmm.
Pretty hot,
isn't it?
I mean there's more,
but this is so well done.
Well,
talk about the first rule of Improv.
Yes.
And yeah,
this a sex lady is really yes.
Anding the shit out of him.
He's really,
yes.
Anding
you have to shit.
I do,
baby.
You want to watch me Shit?
Oh No.
I'll take the big shit.
I like that.
Yeah.
Just watch it come out of my warm hot ass play with the baby.
Just Jack that Jack off.
Yeah.
Where's Barron?
Did we lose Bert?
Me All that watch shit.
Really good.
Yeah.
Quite a shit.
I mean,
think about how like if she's the one working the phone and you're like,
hey,
this person really is taking a shit.
Right.
Wait,
I liked the,
he works in that.
Oh Wow.
[inaudible]
it's only smells
his lap.
She likes it.
Yeah.
I mean you really took a big,
yeah,
he had to find like the perfect,
how does he do it in time?
I always worry he has the soundboard,
so,
yeah.
Yeah.
That's such a throwaway.
Perfect.
Here we go.
Who's this?
Hitler.
Hey,
I'd rather not talk about that
offensive.
Sorry.
Wow.
That's where she draws the line.
A Hitler.
Wow.
You said like,
Hi Hitler.
I'd rather than that.
You probably have like a nice Jewish lady working in the front.
I don't Hitler.
Hey Hillary.
I'd rather not talk about that.
Right back to shitting and she's fine with that,
right?
She's fine with that,
but not a,
not a little high.
Hitler.
Well,
I guess,
I mean that kind of makes sense actually.
Does it?
I mean shit is shit,
but like Hitler,
Hitler,
Nazi stuff.
Sure,
sure.
Here she's had Nazi fantasies where the person's like,
call me Hitler.
Uh,
I dunno.
Maybe she doesn't work those calls.
Hey Wipe,
wipe.
You make it look it up.
Smell it smells good.
It's like I'm killing it.
So you're always in an orgy.
Rob.
Rob,
what's your pronoun?
I don't know.
What do you want it to be?
Kind of weird.
I like that.
She's like,
where's bird?
He's asking for him to step in.
Hmm?
Did you come hug somebody without their consent?
We've opened up a whole other cannabis gets
to be done anymore.
How do you decide what you do that day?
Go with,
do you feel like doing baby?
Go with the flow.
It's silly.
Nazi.
Just go shit.
I like the Shit,
don't you?
Yeah,
I can tell you do.
Of course
we call her for writing lab and at the,
are you kidding me?
This woman's all pro.
Yeah.
How do you guys deal with feelings?
Oh,
for fuck feelings.
I'm over those.
I love to have with what you guys are smoking and tell you that much
everywhere.
I feel like I peed all over the earth.
All over the world.
Because you do sound like a total maniac or is he keeps bringing up.
She's like,
yeah,
but you're like,
I gotta go pee everywhere whenever you want,
but here's your goodbye.
Bye Bye.
Dial it.
I gotta let you go.
You can call it back from what time is he liked?
Okay.
Mine.
You didn't even say Shit Shit.
Wow.
That was really impressive.
That's like a lot of work
and this is the right.
I'd rather not talk about it.
Uh
Oh my.
She really does go with the flow.
The only time she pushed back on us was with the Hitler,
which I,
like.
I said,
I mean,
I just want us to loot Tony God damn telling me that's a lot of work,
you know?
Sure.
Insulated stuff.
Made a soundboard then made a call,
then found somebody to jump in and get involved in it.
It was really good.
Really good.
Jamais yeah,
pretty amaze.
Wow.
I have to admit it's a little weird to hear myself talking like that to a porno
lady.
Are we not?
Whenever I leave a phone sex operator.
Yeah.
How she's on an oldest shit by the way.
She'd been doing it for a minute.
She's been doing it for awhile.
Yeah.
Well smoking to uh,
people,
uh,
wrote in,
they said,
um,
mommies,
I was minding my business last week Hoggins and balls and listening to the show
when I was deeply disturbed by what I was hearing and there isn't much that gets
my stomach turning,
but all the asshole rerouting talk got to me.
Oh,
come on.
Wow.
This is exactly the silly shit I come for when I get to my mommy's house.
Next time.
In the spirit of being sensitive to everyone's a false personal line of decency,
just go ahead and piss on me and beat me.
Your friend Peyton Lafferty,
of course,
this is not from last week,
but the week before,
this is uh,
in reference to Johnny Pemberton discussing his colon being removed.
Goodness.
He had colitis and had to have his intestines rerouted and he had a colostomy
bag.
And head is just,
man,
I thought it was just medically very interesting.
It was very interesting,
but it was difficult to hear,
to struggle with it.
I'm just so thankful.
I've never had to deal with anything like that in my life.
It makes me really thankful to when I was,
oh fuck.
Just looking at him and he's like a teenager when it happens or something.
Right.
Wasn't he like,
like 17 years old a man.
I know.
It's so,
um,
somebody asks,
how much do painters,
right.
I knew we were going to get here.
I knew I wanted to go there after we did.
Boobies.
Yeah.
You know,
twigging berries,
obviously,
you know,
we're not talking about the same kinds of weight.
Not a lot.
I can't imagine a time.
Let's start weighing dicks.
You should also consider Tom having time where five pounds around his neck for a
whole day.
Try it out.
One loan,
Matt,
for Chicago.
Of course.
Math,
talking about what you're walking around with on that chest of yours.
Ooh.
Oh my God.
I don't when the baby belly.
So I've got a baby of a human growing inside of you coming front wise and then
these teds.
Yeah,
it's fucking,
it's a lot dude.
But you know what?
Doing [inaudible] just second time around has really,
really helped because my core strength is a lot better now.
Yeah,
but man,
like gravity wants you to be forward.
Pull you forward.
It's tough.
How's that baby feeling guys kicking around a lot.
He's doing really well.
We're 20 weeks.
I'm halfway there.
Just crazy.
Like the shit down.
Yeah.
Do you like to shit me?
It's all I talk about.
Yeah,
go lab but a brown talk.
If we may do a brown talk.
Update,
update,
pregnancy,
Brown talk.
Pregnancy.
Brown's house.
Oh
next door.
Brown.
Todd Brown.
I got a fart.
Pretty bad.
I feel like.
Go for it.
Where's the Fart Mike?
People are asking you about that.
I know
we never came through on that.
Some people told me they were really disappointed.
I'm really disappointed.
Yeah,
we have extra mikes.
I love to have with you guys are smoking.
We had extra Mike's laying around.
We have the lines.
Can we just have blue band put in a Fort Mike and we can sit it here in the
middle and then when you've got one coming up,
just might need to be on the ground and near your butthole and that's another
arm we need to build.
Can we just put one here and then you just grab the farm?
Mike,
that's a good idea.
It's not that hard guy,
but I do think I have to pause for a brown.
Yeah.
Are you being serious,
serious thing?
I have to.
Okay.
What?
Do you remember what you were about to say?
Of course.
We'll make note of it so that we can I go.
I'll go pee.
All right.
I'm going to take a shit.
She's screaming.
Yeah,
that's going to be bad.
Okay.
I can tell what's going to be really starting to be good.
All right.
Oh,
how did that Brown go?
God,
it was very necessary.
What do you think it was?
I don't know.
We had healthy lunch.
There wasn't a splatter,
it wasn't a blaster or anything like that.
What was it like?
I mean it was just ready to go,
but it was the one,
we have a number.
I mean,
I think it was like a four and a half.
Oh,
okay.
Almost a five.
Okay.
Interesting.
But the urgency was there.
Oh yeah,
I was ready.
So,
um,
what I was going to tell you about pregnancy poops is different because,
uh,
as uterus,
your uterus grows and expands.
It squishes up your intestines.
Yeah.
And progesterone increase makes you constipated,
your digestion slows down.
So now my poops were like rabbit turds and it can hit me at any time.
Like my schedule's all off.
I really have to sit down and focus to make the Brown.
It's kind of a disaster.
Wow.
I mean,
I should this morning,
but I just have to be really cognizant of like,
when the urge strikes,
I gotta I just gotta honor it.
You know,
you got to follow the,
yeah.
It's just going to get harder from here on out to once the baby gets bigger and
bigger,
doing a lot of this stuff by the way of what style?
Multiple,
multiple browns all the time.
Well,
they're small.
I sit down to Brown and that's like kibble.
It's like rabbit shit.
And then I just have to keep doing.
I have to keep at it until you get something worth talking about.
Would you like to,
I mean there's usually a push present,
you know.
Are you interested at all in this at all or no.
Bridget Boudreaux takes milestones and turns them into treasures.
Moms appreciate most
breast milk is liquid gold.
Braswell is your diamond made from you?
I cultured pearls out of your own breast milk and it's something that you cannot
buy off the shelf.
Do you think I'm going to pass?
I could reach out to her.
Joe Breen mill charms.
Joe From my son,
Joey brief from Bridget came to be after the birth of her son Joey.
And when you breastfeed is something that you do all day and all night.
So I really wanted to commemorate the bond that that creates between only mother
and child.
Mm.
So you have breast milk jewelry.
Um,
I'd rather take like a diamond ring.
The breast looks more unique.
I don't want a breast milk ring.
I want a diamond ring.
I want to do the breast milk one.
A photo of it on Facebook got noticed.
Now orders are coming in from across the US.
Every single piece is unique to them and their stories.
I have made a memorial piece for a few babies that have passed.
Wait a minute,
is she making it with her own breast milk?
Are you sending in your breast milk?
I would imagine you're sending in your work though.
There's,
you're not just getting your,
now you got to ship it.
I understand.
And then she takes about three months for the stay at home mom to fill an order.
The customized charms costs between 50 and $200 500 moms ship their breast milk
to Bridgette last year.
Wow.
No,
now,
but this has to be a severe health hazard.
First of all,
you're not allowed to FedEx any fluids of any kind.
We know that.
So you cannot send your body fluids via the man.
Hundred moms just did.
You're not supposed to.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure Fedex doesn't let you send Tj's or farts or whatever.
Breast milk.
Yeah.
They'll never smelled bad.
Never Rot.
A mother of two turning a milestone for some women.
This is the very last drop aggressive on if they have into a moment that can now
last.
A lifetime reporter is making this sound really serious.
Yeah.
And not,
not giving it the good natured ribbing it deserves
the last time.
And that's kind of symptomatic of our era that we're living in,
that everybody has to be honored and treated like it's rational,
insane.
And you can't call crazy people crazy anymore.
Right.
This budget and crazy.
She's honoring her breast milk,
right?
No,
you can't just call people what they fucking are anymore.
God forbid,
was pretty crazy.
Gene,
is there anything else?
Well,
I mean,
uh,
I just want to talk about you being a Starbucks aficionado.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I appreciate it.
Get you light up.
You're ready to tap out of this episode and I promise you that good service.
And that's the thing is,
you know what I find that irritates me more than bad service of people who
justify bad service or who think that it's not worth pointing out that there's
bad service.
There's,
they're the worst people on earth and they're there.
The reason why bad service continues because these people are like,
what's the big deal if somebody sucks at a job that you're paying for it,
why don't you just let them suck?
Cause some people take pride in their job and should be celebrated.
Good Service.
Yeah.
Cause you go into some of these places,
not just start,
but I'm talking to any service place and you know,
it's awful and you're there just in a bad mood or they just don't care and
you're like,
this sucks.
Yeah.
I like to celebrate the ones where it's really good.
Don't you love it?
I think if you had ever,
if I was the person waiting on you at any of the numerous service jobs I'd had,
you would have hated me complaining.
Like I don't think,
man,
I complain to you.
I don't actually,
I don't call the manager over now.
I was a decent Barista and there may have been a decent server at times,
but overall I'd never cared.
I wasn't,
I'm not good at the service industry.
I like efficiency.
I like when they,
they don't have to know my name or any of that shit.
You like it?
Everybody does.
You said today you go,
we're going to go cause there's three Starbucks locations and are never had.
Yes.
And we did a run down of which one we should go to.
Well the,
the,
the one that we used to go to all the time that drive through one,
that one's not really good.
Why now?
Why is that?
I find them to be just fine.
Really fine.
They're inconsistent.
That's,
that's something that I realize is very nice in the server.
Consistent how with their,
how they treat you or the product products and sometimes they make it right.
So a lot of times they make it wrong.
It's pretty simple order.
They get it wrong a lot.
Um,
you know,
what is your order so that we will come back the layers pretty easy going ahead.
Venti,
iced coffee,
extra ice,
venti coffee would go ahead.
Ice,
venti coffee,
extra ice,
no sweetener.
Small Splash of whole milk.
And when you say a splash,
you do mean just a hint.
That's it.
Um,
yeah,
sometimes I'm in the store
and I'll say that.
And then I watched the person take the milk and they go the blue two,
two,
two.
I'm like,
hey no,
that's not going to work.
What?
It's not going to work.
You just gave me a glass of milk.
Right.
I don't want to drink a glass of milk.
That's yeah.
Yeah.
So I actually found a way around it though.
What's the way I asked for a whole milk on the side so I don't even have to put
it on the person anymore.
Okay.
I didn't realize you could do that.
Cause I will say there nothing strikes terror in my heart more than how many get
your ice coffee or iced venti coffee.
Yeah.
Uh,
because I know that I have to put that splash of whole milk and for you.
Yeah.
And if it's not the right color of blond,
yeah.
You get very upset.
Very.
And it's extra eyes.
If there's not enough ice in there and you get upset.
And I like,
I swear to God,
it induces a little bit of panic and anxiety in me.
No,
it does.
I'm sure.
Cause I don't want you to be unhappy.
I don't like that.
I'm not that.
No,
you don't get mad.
But I know that it,
it disappoints you and I don't like to disappoint you.
Sorry Sweetie.
You,
I don't feel like I'm that crazy about it,
but I do like it mate.
You know,
you like your thing made the way you like it.
So,
but like I said,
I found that,
that I no longer ask for it.
I asked for now the whole milk on the side.
I go,
give me a little.
Sure.
So,
so the drive through one is you found that they're inferior in their consistency
and quality product.
Now the other location is in a very busy parking lot.
And what's wrong with that place?
It's too crazy.
It's chaos there.
The parking,
you mean the parking place itself?
It's very small.
It's,
it's tough now.
The one that's good also gets too busy so I will skip that one too.
Okay.
But yeah,
that one's your favorite of the three locations.
Why?
No,
because it's good.
It's good service that has people in there are in a good,
it just shows you,
it's like I'm not even asking for it.
People that work there in a good mood,
they're always pretty happy.
They treat everybody really well.
Uh,
they get really busy and they still maintain their composure.
Yeah.
I mean they're,
they're super nice.
Yeah.
Well,
and you said that they know your name now and I know your drink.
Yeah.
Some of them do.
Probably like half of them do and that you let it go there all the time,
but yeah,
but,
but you like that,
that they know you're sure,
but like that's what anybody likes from a service.
Yeah.
You know,
is that the person they remember you,
they say your name,
they go,
I know that you like your thing like this.
It's like going to a restaurant where they go like,
oh,
you always get the ham and cheese or whatever.
Yeah.
Well I think Starbucks is like in and out and that they take pride in training
their employees very well.
They treat their employees very well.
They make sure the employees are aware of the products and what everything is
about and everything.
You don't sell them well.
You have a Starbucks knows.
Pick thanks.
Sell them.
We have a Starbucks employee who was like,
I don't know.
I don't know what that drink is.
I don't know what that Frappaccino is.
They fucking know.
Yeah,
they're trained.
They're trained,
they're trained man.
They're good there.
I love
Starbucks.
I love it.
I know.
Fuck Pete's coffee.
I fucking hate it.
It seems like the cost he nails.
I don't know.
I kind of,
I don't mind the coffee bean.
I don't like it.
I've I,
it's okay.
I'll say this is mine.
They're trained well
and they,
the,
the employees actually are,
are usually really nice there.
Yeah,
but I don't like their iced coffee and that's my drink.
I liked the vanilla latte.
I liked the vanilla powder.
Sometimes you get used to a certain taste.
You can't go away from it.
So whenever I have an ice coffee with there,
I'm like,
ugh.
Some people hate Starbucks.
I know.
Burnt tasting.
Pete's just tastes like dirt down.
I don't like that.
I had it the other day at the airport.
I want to throw up.
I don't like it at all.
All right.
Uh,
and Dunkin donuts can go fuck itself.
That is the worst water.
Terrible.
Yeah.
Gene,
this is a,
why am h dunkers by Dj?
Please come to Nashville.
Come back to Nashville for fuck sake.
That's the name of the Dj Nashville.
Oh,
and thanks to everybody ordering the,
uh,
not Los Angeles shirt.
A limited audience of Angelenos by,
it's a funny shirt,
man.
Caleb,
thanks for the design,
the mugs.
Uh,
don't you hate everyone.
And next dot.
Brown talk mugs,
a couple other shirts and there's some new stuff coming out that,
um,
will be in the store soon.
Thanks again for listening and thanks for supporting our sponsors by gene.
My head sizes like two chicken,
chicken,
chicken.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Big tits.
And after quadruple
drops out there,
that has sloppy,
sloppy,
sloppy jump,
jump,
big tits,
big,
big
drops out.
Does that make sense?